[Music]
on this wednesday night grim
projections for ontario what the newest
covid19
modeling predicts plus small businesses
struggle to pay rent as help from ottawa
ends demanding justice for joyce
eshequan
she's saying herself you know weeks
before
one day they're gonna kill me outrage
grows over the callous treatment of the
indigenous woman
her family says it was part of a pattern
the most
unpresidential of debates there's
nothing smart about you would you say
was america the biggest loser and what
was trump's message to white
supremacists
plus flipping the script the vancouver
international film festival goes
virtual
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we say goodbye to september a month
when canadians got back to school
and to work there are signs this
country's biggest province is not
getting a grip on the rising cases of
covet 19.
in the last 24 hours 625 more ontarians
tested positive
most of them in the toronto peel and
ottawa regions
it is the seventh day in a row more than
400 new people have been diagnosed
public health officials say cases in
ontario are now doubling every 10 to 12
days
if that keeps up they project ontario
could hit
000 cases a day by mid-october though
the bulk of the infections are in
younger people case numbers are now
rising in all age groups and if older
people get sick in greater numbers
that could overwhelm ontario hospitals
they are already urging the government
to reimpose tougher restrictions in the
hot spot regions
before case numbers spiral out of
control premier doug ford says he's not
ready to do that
yet eric sorenson has our top story
cracks are emerging in what has been a
united front by public health officials
to combat the covet 19 pandemic
a consortium of specialists in ontario
have modeled the future
expecting a rise in cases and more
worryingly in the need for icu beds
last spring other surgeries were
cancelled to accommodate covid19
patients
in april and may close to 300 icu beds
were assigned
to covet 19 patients the number fell
sharply for months but in recent days
has risen to 35
the modeling consensus projects the need
will keep rising this fall
if the number stays below 150 icu beds
hospitals can manage covid and non-covet
demands
above 150 in the medium scenario
non-coveted cases become harder to
support
above 350 and the crisis could be worse
than in the spring
we are trying to maintain our health
care system and in fact
bring up our volume on procedures
much has been discussed about the impact
of closing procedures
that we did back in the spring we are
trying to not do that
in recent days ontario has lowered the
limit on private gatherings and
tightened restrictions on businesses
selling food and alcohol
some specialists say it's not enough in
the face of a new wave of cases
to sit back and watch and see how uh
closing strip clubs and
capping drinking time in bars to a few
hours earlier
see how that does in terms of bending
this curve it's not
plausible to me that it will have a
significant impact meantime there is a
growing backlog in testing
at a time when more tests will be needed
with children in school
and flu season coming so this has always
been about breaking the chains of
transmission always about having
aggressive uh testing capacity and
ability
and then ensuring you have appropriate
contact tracing to break those trains of
those chains of transmission
ontario's premier suggested it's a
difficult balance keeping ontarians safe
from this persistent coronavirus
while also keeping the economy as
healthy as possible you have to measure
you know the impacts to the people's
livelihoods and
so i take the economy very very
seriously
it's not the same as when we were before
we we know a lot more
we're better prepared we have the ppes
nothing
we do is just a quick decision bang do
it but the pressure is mounting from
some health
experts to do just that more targeted
lockdowns
sooner rather than later erik sorensen
global news
toronto canada is now consistently
reporting more than 1 000
new cases a day most of today's new ones
are in
ontario and quebec quebec accounting for
838 new cases
manitoba has 40. further west alberta
has 153 new cases
and b.c 125. small business owners in
canada have their
own projection for the coming months and
it looks dire
not just is revenue down for many
businesses the federal commercial rent
assistance program
expires today it was a flawed program
but at least it was something
the canadian federation of independent
business says 31 percent of its members
didn't qualify for the rent assistance
program either their landlord didn't
apply for it or they didn't meet the
criteria
of a 70 percent reduction in revenue the
government has promised to improve and
replace the program but
that hasn't happened yet and rent is due
tomorrow
mike gerlay explains the anxiety that is
causing
a chill is set in on the service
industry and it's not just from the fall
weather
restaurant owners had been banking on a
return to normalcy
if we're not operating at 100 we can't
make money but with covet 19 numbers on
the rise
that's looking unlikely the 23 firkin
pubs in ontario have survived
but only barely rent relief had been
their lifeline but the government
program called secra
has come to an end leaving tenants on
the hook for 100
of their rent we have to have programs
in place to carry us
all the way through to the summer of
next year without that the industry is
going to collapse not just working
if the government is working on a
replacement program it's not saying
at least not with any specifics we're
aware of that
and i can tell you that we're not going
to let them down a vague promise
which isn't good enough for an industry
that's working with very real numbers
the reality is that the math just stops
working for restaurants no matter how
hard you work no matter how innovative
you are
if you're a business that operates on
five percent margins but fifty percent
of your business is gone
there's just no way to make that math
work secret for all it did
was deeply flawed it had a budget of
three billion dollars yet just over half
was dispersed
business experts say the criteria to
qualify were far too narrow
so obviously i think they need to either
change the focus
of of the future program and make it
much more easier and simpler for the end
user to use it
and the government better announce
something soon because rent is due
and businesses on the brink have some
big decisions to make
anxiety is is putting it mildly i think
for a lot of business owners right
rent is just a huge expense mike relay
global news toronto
a series of new emergency aid benefits
including expanded eligibility for sick
leave are coming after legislation was
passed in parliament
it's intended to fill the gaps left
behind by the serb the emergency benefit
that's now ended
there was opposition from some mps to
the legislation but that vanished
overnight
and today conservative leader aaron
o'toole and block quebecois leader e
francois blanchette were
back on parliament hill after recovering
from covet 19.
as michael couture reports it didn't
take long for things to get tense
the honorable leader of the opposition
erin o'toole's first question period as
leader of the official opposition
started with pleasantries as prime
minister justin trudeau welcomed him
back to the house
after recovering from covet 19. then
the gloves came off with o'toole
attacking trudeau
when are canadians finally going to
receive rapid testing
in response the prime minister pointed
out health canada has now approved the
abbott id
now rapid testing system that comes a
day
after the government signed a deal to
secure 7.9 million
of those tests we can now be deployed
for provinces and territories
with deliveries coming in the coming
weeks mr speaker
it comes after a late night vote on the
government's amended legislation to help
workers affected by covet 19.
the liberals limited debate on the aid
arguing canadians couldn't wait for the
help
but there is concern it lacked proper
scrutiny
the fact that we were not invited to do
what we were elected for
is a problem the government suddenly
made bill c-4 the pandemic economic
package a confidence vote
essentially to force the hand of all
other parties
voting against it would have caused an
election where the liberals
would have been able to blame the
opposition and claim they were standing
in the way
of getting much-needed help to canadians
donna okay mike look at it thanks only
about three million canadians have
downloaded the federal covid alert
app in part because the technology is
not available to everyone
the federal government developed the app
but it's up to the provinces to adopt it
and as heather urex west explains
western provinces are still waiting for
changes to be made
early in the pandemic alberta was first
out of the gate
launching an app that could help with
covid 19 contact tracing
but there were big problems with
alberta's trace together problems now
solved in another app developed by the
federal government
what i would stress is that this is a
very different app
and it's one that has wide backing and
it's one that's been lauded not just in
canada but
internationally as being a really
right-headed way of approaching this
problem
problem is the federal covet alert app
is still not available in alberta
in fact so far it's only been adopted in
ontario saskatchewan new brunswick and
newfoundland and labrador
a senior source with the federal
government says the delays
boil down to jurisdiction ottawa can't
impose the app on provincial governments
and some provinces don't get feel the
app fully meets their needs
i spoke to minister haider i think it
was last week
i think there were still a couple issues
still still a couple
questions that were remaining to be
answered it is an ongoing discussion
the team with the federal government is
working with individual
provinces at the same sequentially so we
are on that list
but we are also working with them to to
make some adjustments that will meet our
needs
but other holdouts are now coming around
some provinces who weren't really
interested in that before like quebec
for example have really recently said
okay we're in the middle of the second
wave and suddenly just in the last few
days
something that they were resistant
they've suddenly agreed to start rolling
up the app
and manitoba says it could adopt the app
as early as next week
still territorial governments say the
app wouldn't be well suited for its
citizens
wi-fi access up north is not widespread
but for the rest of the country health
canada says it's hopeful the app will
become a widely used weapon
in the fight against colvin 19's second
wave heather urex west global news
calgary
hospital staff taunted and insulted
joyce eshequan in her final hours alive
coming up the amplifying demands for
answers
the calls for answers are growing louder
and the anger is building over how an
indigenous woman was treated in a quebec
hospital
joyce eschequan recorded video of her
last moments alive as staff made
racist and callous comments about her
she lay strapped to a bed and was
pleading with them to help her
they appeared indifferent and she died a
short time later
eshequan a 37-year-old indigenous woman
was the mother of seven children ranging
in age from
seven months to 21 years indigenous
leaders say her video exposes the
realities of systemic racism
as felicia perillo reports three
investigations are underway into her
death
and a warning some viewers may find the
video disturbing
37-year-old joyce eshequan leaves behind
her children
a husband family friends and an entire
community
on monday during the last moments of her
life eshequan recorded herself
pleading for help as nurses mocked her
and called her name
family members say eshequan was speaking
in a ticomit her mother tongue
saying she was being given too much
medication
and that's exactly what family members
believe led to her death
we don't need much investigation said a
cousin we know the facts
we saw the recordings we saw her
condition
family and friends say this wasn't an
isolated incident
according to them eshequan had been
treated at the jaliet hospital before
and had experienced racism during past
visits
it was like a couple of times that she
had experienced
and she she say herself you know weeks
before
one day they're gonna kill me on tuesday
quebec's premier francois lego announced
that a nurse involved in the incident
had been fired and that investigations
were underway
but the family doesn't think that's good
the enough of one nurse doesn't fix
anything there wasn't just
one nurse in the video there were three
he says
cindy blackstock executive director of
the first nations child and family
caring society
believes the blame goes beyond just the
hospital staff
involved so often we look at individual
actions
and that's where we focus our attention
on racial discrimination
and that's an important place but often
it's reinforced at the systemic level
and even by governments themselves
the premier denies systemic racism
played a role in neshaquan's death
but quebec's first aboriginal surgeon
says that
is simply untrue systemic racism is
present here
as it is across the country that's
happening
throughout canada in toronto winnipeg
vancouver montreal
halifax so we have to
act as a country as a province to
go against systemic racism the regional
health authority denied our request for
an interview
but in a statement said there are three
levels of investigations underway
they added that internal meetings are
taking place to determine if there will
be
more disciplinary actions against any
other staff
who were involved felicia parilla global
news
juliette quebec proud boys and the
president ahead why didn't trump condemn
white supremacists
if you watched the u.s presidential
debate last night you'll appreciate this
the organizers say they recognize the
need for additional
structure in the format for the two
remaining debates to ensure they say a
more
orderly discussion because last night
was
well it's been described by people
across the political spectrum
is undignified unpresidential and a
total disaster
here are a couple of hot takes from u.s
news channels
that is humiliating for us as a country
this was
a joke this sort of debate shouldn't
happen in a democracy
i'm just gonna say it like it is that
was a show
even the fox news morning show which
president trump is known to watch
used a visual aid to coach him for next
time
here's my advice for the president on
the next debate
one interrupt less there was
no winner and the loser it seems was
democracy in
america one moment that stood out above
the shouting was when president trump
was asked directly if he was willing to
condemn white supremacists and militia
groups
he was not instead he said they should
stand back and
stand by that chilling message is what
jackson proskow is looking into tonight
i don't know who the proud boys are i
mean you have to give me a definition
because i really don't know who they are
i can only say they have to stand down
let law enforcement do their work
suddenly president donald trump claims
not to know of the group he directed to
stand down
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists
during a debate in which he refused to
distance himself from white supremacists
and armed militias
and instead seemed to send them a
message he didn't do it sir say it
do it say it do you want to call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white supremacy
boys stand back and stand by but i'll
tell you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
the proud boys trump mentioned have a
history of violent protests
founded by canadian gavin mcginnis
they've been designated a hate group by
the southern poverty law center
trump's words are already being seen by
its members and other white supremacists
as a call to action
getting instructions from the president
on a nationally
televised platform is a dream of groups
like the proud boys
it takes on added significance with an
election that may be close or even
disputed
both candidates were asked if they would
urge their supporters to stay calm
i'm encouraging my supporters to go into
the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen i am
urging them to do it spreading baseless
conspiracies about fraud
trump has called on an army of his
voters to serve as poll watchers on
election day
in states with open carry laws some of
them could be armed
a potential method of voter intimidation
we don't know the criteria they're using
we just know that they've already been
told
that their irregularities um taking
place and so they're coming in looking
for trouble
it's another layer to trump's long
complicated history with the far right
a group whose support he knows is not up
for debate
as for the debate it's too soon to tell
if it moved the needle with undecided
voters in any sort of a meaningful way
but early polls do suggest it did not
help with already negative views of
president trump donna okay jackson in
washington thank you
[Music]
well if you're a woman of a certain age
like me this helen ready song from 1972
helped shape how you saw your place in
the world reddy has died at the age of
78.
she wrote the lyrics after being
belittled and harassed by male
executives and performers
it became not just a number one song but
a feminist anthem
i am strong
[Music]
a royal canadian air force helicopter is
back in the skies after it was roughed
up earlier this month in northern
labrador
this is the damage crews woke up to a
huge muddy
footprint of a polar bear the air force
says no crew members were around during
the bear's nighttime visit and the
superficial damage was
easily repaired the vancouver film
festival was nearly canceled this year
by the pandemic but
organizers have found a way to keep the
annual event going
as robin gill explains though
stay-at-home cinema is a competitive
field
the curse of willow's song eerily
mirrors the current pandemic
the main character has to spend a lot of
time alone
living with uncertainty the movie got
the attention of the vancouver
international film festival
and won best british columbia film it's
always a shock isn't it when you win
anything
lawyer turned filmmaker karen lamb hopes
there's an audience
beyond the judges because the festival
is coming to you
in your living room i did film it for a
an actual big screen
so there's a lot of sound design and a
lot of details that
i wonder how much that translates when
it's actually online
on it and on a smaller screen then
there's the competition for eyeballs
from other online options
like netflix or amazon it's much easier
to to turn something off online than it
is to walk out of a cinema i think
normally there would be 300 films at vif
that's been paired down to a hundred
a ticket to each film normally costs
between 15 to 17 dollars per film
raking in over a million dollars in
revenue
now there's a 60 dollar subscription so
far 5 000 people have signed up
and close to 6 000 single tickets have
sold
there will be a handful of screenings
for 50 people maxed at the newly
renovated
vif center and that 2.7 million dollar
facelift
has been a gift given the constraints of
the pandemic that we were going to be
able to
have this all completed to the extent
that it is
there's still that nostalgia for the way
things used to be but the times
they have changed and like every other
industry
this too has to adjust it feels like the
films that we made were right before the
pandemic
and um it feels like is this the last
film we get to make in this sort of way
you know before is it going to shift the
way that we tell
stories is it going to shift the way
that we film the answer
probably yes who knows but the one a
surety for lamb is that she can take
this time to enjoy the praise
for her work robin gill global news
vancouver
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the sun
setting in belleville ontario we'd love
to see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye